the T by renfa platform provides a
powerful environment to process analyze
and integrate multi-omics data as you
can see a variety of data types are
available including next-generation
sequencing mass spectroscopy structural
biology and a separate section for data
integration and modeling to start using
the platform you can request a free
14-day demo account where you will have
access to almost full capabilities of
the platform
besides the uploading of the data now
you can see that each section will have
a drop-down arrow as we will continue
more demo pipelines will be added so
that you can play around with the
different sections of the platform as an
example you can see a demo pipeline
right here for RNA seek there is no need
to upload the data you just go ahead and
click on the start button to read a
brief tutorial about how to use this
section for example RNA c consists of
three basic steps pre-processing mapping
and quantification of expression levels
down here you will see an example
pipeline so that you know which sections
to select as we go through building of
the pipeline each pop-up will provide
some insight into what this method does
and will offer a link to a tutorial
where you can read about this algorithm
once you have completed preparing your
pipeline you will see that the output
files from this pipeline are already a
part of the pipeline results and you
don't have to wait for the pipeline to
process because no new data has been
uploaded you click right here and you
will see some of the outputs that you
typically get in such a pipeline all
results in a zip folder some tab
delimited tables and the mapping
statistics
the same demo pipelines are available
for some other sections you can go under
variant calling and build a pipeline
that will show you how we can call
somatic mutations or run visualization
using J browse
one of the major values this platform
provides is in the ability to integrate
multi-omics data we started adding
several examples of how you might use
which data type and how to use the
methods on the platform when you click
on the start button you will learn about
how to prepare the data in this example
you can see that two tables from a
different comic type where the samples
are column names and features are rows
they don't have to have the same
features but the samples have to be
named exactly the same you can also see
an example table RNA editing table and
RNA expression we can use o - pls to
help visualize the data in the same
multi-dimensional space you can also
right-click on a button if you want to
go one step back SNF tools provides a
method for similarity Network fusion it
is essentially a clustering technique
that will cluster the data based on both
types of the omics after you click on OK
click on the arrow to see the output of
the method that you selected
to request your demo account you can
reach out to us or click on this access
button and fill out your name so that we
will send you an email with a password
so that you can access this platform and
play around with the demo pipelines